and these guys went crazy for you you
were like that's us we've changed so
much it's hard and it's long and we're
doing school and we're doing work and
it's all kind of in this jumble and you
got to stay professional and we've done
that but I think I would just if I could
go back I would just say just enjoy it
keep grindin and learn yeah yeah and it
is gonna be like a 75% is not usable
kids choice high-energy who do you bring
as your partner in crime well today I
brought my sister she was excited about
it so this is one of the first events
that we've come to together usually it's
my dad and I were kind of a dream team
but I thought I'd bring her today what
was it like to come back for descendants
to in van City
it was great it was great I was a I was
pumped I was so excited I think
everybody was excited you know I feel
like for me after the first movie ended
I was just like alright what the next
one like oh I want to get to it is how
to be up the ante for a second it's
gonna be difficult honestly right
because I mean the first one was really
big and when we first heard about you
know we were doing a sequel we were like
alright how are we gonna top the first
one but I think we did I think that
everything is bigger the sets the the
choreography the numbers all of it is a
really high energy and high stakes and
stuff like that so it's pretty it's
pretty fun I guess you could say it has
been a little bit more of a challenge
just incorporating new people and you
know having to give back in dancing
shapes and things like that so yeah but
it was you know so good I could feel
muscles that I didn't know were there a
couple days ago so yeah we've been
really sore and I think we did like a
nine hour dance rehearsal one day so
it's it's intense but you know it'll
it'll turn out pretty good just a whole
lot of dancing just a whole lot of
really intense choreography I love it
that's my favorite part
that's my favorite part
sans Cameron's passing several stars
have posted heartfelt tributes for the
actor on social media
his descendants co-starred of Cameron
uploaded a tearful black-and-white video
on Instagram saying goodbye to her
friend and brother
goodbye dear friends you leave behind a
colossal wake a profound chasm that can
never be filled but you also leave
millions and millions of deeply impacted
hope filled and love filled human beings
who are who they are because of you and
how you spent your brief 20 years on
this earth
Cameron's Jessie co-star Skye Jackson
got emotional speaking to et at the Lion
King premiere he was like a brother to
me so it's very sad and he was just a
happy person so it's very unfortunate
but we're gonna continue its legacy and
I know he would be proud of us so yeah
suicide and Adam Sandler who played
Cameron's on-screen dad and grownups
tweeted his condolences writing quote
too young too sweet too funny just the
nicest most talented and most decent kid
around loved that kid